- Yeah, I feel like it's
like spending quality time
with yourself when you're taking selfies.
You know, it's therapeutic.
- That's a really nice way
to look at it.
- Yeah
- I don't think selfies
are that annoying.
- For me,
- I kind of like them.
- It's so uncomfortable
- And they're fun!
- For me, I've tried
- Selfies?
- I agree, I think it's so weird.
- Milo, people demand
more selfies from you.
You gotta just get over your fear.
- I keep trying to take them and post them
because people, you know, want them.
- We want them.
- And then I show my
friends, and is this good?
And they're like, "That is awful."
- Don't show your friends.
- That is terrible.
- No,
- Don't show your friends.
- I can't just posted it.
- Yeah, you can.
- Milo is the King.
Go to Milo's Instagram.
All it is, and Andrew Collins, my buddy.
- Oh, I've been on his Instagram.
- All it is is him with different girls.
He has, you have more
girlfriends than anyone I know.
- I'm a theater kid, I'm a theater kid.
There's like two guys in the theater.
- You look like you're
constantly hosting the View.
- Honestly.
- Like a teenage version of the view.
There's like four women
of different ethnicities
around you at a table.
- Yeah, it's become a running joke.
- He's the united colors of Benton nine.
- It's become a running
joke on my Instagram
that I post, all my friends
are girls, it's just how it is.
So I post with new girls all the time,
and it's become a joke
that everyone's like,
"Oh my god, is he dating this person now?"
And now whenever I post a
photo, I just posted a photo
of me at a party and in
the back there's a balloon,
and it's like, "Oh my god,
he's dating the balloon."
(rock music)
- From Dancing with the
Stars, the movie Zombies,
teen sensation, Milo Manheim is here.
- A teen sensation, that's a stretch.
- Yeah, friend of the show, I mean,
this is the third appearance.
- I know, I love it here.
- This is old hat for you.
- Yeah, for real.
I feel like I know
everything about this place.
- Our other guest, a good friend of yours,
a good friend of mine from
Dancing with the Stars,
from Instagram, an entrepreneur
in and of her own right,
just such a strong, cool
woman, Alexis Ren is here.
- Oh, hi.
- Yeah.
- Hi girl.
- Hi.
- Thank you for being here.
- Yeah, I actually didn't know
I was gonna come until you texted me.
- I know.
Alexis was, everyone's
scrambling at Serious
being like, "How did you get Alexis Renn?
"Like can we figure out?
How did you book that bitch?
It's because you're my friend.
- How did you book that bitch?
- Yeah, they said that.
That's how they talk
internally at Serious.
- [Andrew] How did you book that bitch?
(laughs)
- [Milo] From the president.
- It's lovingly, yeah.
No, but you're a huge get obviously,
because you don't do a lot of stuff.
I was trying to look at other stuff.
I was scared to ask you,
'cause I never wanna ask my famous friends
to do something and make
them feel obligated to do it
just cause they're friends.
- Yeah.
- So I was very gentle about
it, and you're like, "Sure."
In your bubbly Alexis Renn
way, and then I was like,
I'll book her on a day that Milo's there,
so she'll feel comfortable
because they know each other.
They're friends.
- I know, did you see
our entrance earlier?
- I know it was crazy.
- Oh my god, them greeting each other
was one of,
- [Alexis] It was like a
dirty dancing hug.
- [Milo] I know, for real.
- I was like, are you guys filming
a package for Dancing with the Stars?
- I honestly fell back on
Dancing with the Stars.
- Why is this hug taking five minutes,
but I appreciate you saying
yes that you'd be here,
but you would have not said yes
had you known it was
7:00 A.M. and not P.M.
- I thought when you meant
show, I thought you meant
like a show that like I go and sit down.
- Dude, are you joking me.
- Yeah, so when you texted
me, I was like, "A.M.?"
And then I thought about it,
and I was like, "Oh, no."
I would have said yes, like
if I would've known earlier.
- You thought a comedy show.
- Yeah.
- That you were gonna
sit in the crowd for.
- From like 7 P.M. to 9 P.M.,
and I would just come and then hope to god
you wouldn't roast me.
- Oh my god.
And then this is so
different than what that is.
- Very different.
- And then I gave you, I
just kept giving you outs,
because I just didn't ever
want you to just be here
and not wanna be here, and you
didn't take any of my outs,
and I appreciate you being here, because,
and I appreciate all of you being here.
This is, I can't believe how
stacked this deck is, today.
- It's pretty good.
- We're chillin'.
- This is star power.
- [Andrew] This is big time.
Alexis was here.
She was here pretty early.
I pulled in she was already there.
- Oh really?
- [Andrew] She was there for
like three or four hours.
- [Alexis] So you know how you
have to write a note on your car?
- Yeah, I know that's part of it.
- I didn't have a pen.
So I used my eyeliner.
- Oh my god!
- Oh, wow.
- [Andrew] That works.
- That's the most Alexis move
I've ever seen you pull.
- It does work.
It works just like eyeliner.
Or just like a pen.
That's such a good idea.
I've done it a bunch.
Also, make up, not only can work as pens,
but blush can work as eye
shadow can work as lip stuff.
- It's all a scam.
- Don't limit yourself.
- Anything, it's all the same.
- It's all the same.
And they keep making up
new stuff that we need.
- They're like a lip stain.
I was like you can use
that anywhere on your face.
- A lip stain can be used everywhere.
- I don't even know what that is.
- Yes you do.
- See.
- After Dancing with
the Stars?
- Lip stain?
- You don't know?
- Do you miss your
spray tans, Milo?
- Stop, I'm gonna cry.
- Okay, these two cutie
patooties are catching up
about Dancing with the Stars
because they went all the way.
They went to the finals Andrew.
- [Andrew] Really?
- They were in the top four.
They both lost.
(laughs)
Let me remind you both that you lost.
- She's not wrong, she's not wrong.
- Who was worse?
- But we lost together.
- Who lost more tragically?
- No we went down, we went down.
- Just both bad?
- That's the thing.
It's like I guess there's a
place, like everyone places.
I didn't really know the placing.
I don't care to know.
It doesn't matter.
- [Milo] Yeah.
- You guys all won, all
the top four won, 'cause--
- Cause you got to dance the last dance
that you possibly could.
- Exactly.
- You got as much screen
time as everyone else.
- As many dances as you
could've done, we did.
- I remember when we first met.
We were at Good Morning
America and I was like,
"Wouldn't it be cool is we made
it to the finals together?"
- We did it.
- That's huge.
- I honestly, I'm gonna
say this right now.
I don't think I've ever told you this,
but when we were at Good
Morning America the first time,
I've said this on the show before,
but I want you to hear it.
When I met you, I totally
knew who you were.
- I knew you knew who I was.
- Okay you're good.
- And then you unfollowed
me, then you followed me.
- Was I not that smooth?
- You think I don't fuckin' know that?
- So you just kept unfollowing
her, and following her,
just so she would see it?
- No, I unfollowed her,
- Trolling hard.
- So he could be back stage, and be like,
"Are you on Instagram?"
- Who are you?
What's your name?
I had been following her for
like three years or something.
- I know, and you liked some
of my photos, and I knew that.
- That's what gave it away.
Also, I tagged you in a
photo of mine two years ago
as a joke, 'cause I was
getting on a private jet
and I tagged myself as Jay Alvarez
and my friend was Alexis Renn.
- Oh god.
- I know.
- So, you instantly saw through it,
because you knew who he was,
and knew that he had liked
something of yours before?
- I didn't know who he was.
- At the time.
- But once I found out who
was gonna be on the show.
- Burn!
- Roasted.
- Sorry, sorry.
- You went back in?
- I did my research.
I was like, "Who's gonna
be on the show this time?"
- I have a lot of hope for these two.
- That's really nice that this is
who unfollows and follows each other.
Mine is like, there's a dude that trolls
me lately that's almost naked.
He's got his six pack.
Yeah, I'll show you the photo.
He does it every single day.
He unfollows and follows and
then likes a bunch of pictures,
and then probably unlikes
them, and likes them again.
I think I gotta fuck this dude.
- Is he into you sexually?
- [Andrew] Yes!
- You have to, the effort!
Alexis, if every guy
who put that much effort
to get your attention on Instagram,
you had to have sex with,
you'd be a busy lady.
- Oh god, that's disgusting.
- I know.
I'm sorry to even put that image in.
He was the one that brought up
he has to have sex with him.
- Time consuming.
- Well I have a lot of dude trolling.
- I'll send my DMs your way.
How about that?
- Yeah, please.
I love it.
I actually collect them.
Some of the girlfriends of
mine, I send, my friend Allie,
I make her send me all
the like filthy nasty shit
that dudes DM her, 'cause I just keep 'em.
I think they're so much fun.
- Yeah, they're pretty.
- Some of the shit are odd.
Some guy like, "I want
you to fart in my mouth."
- Oh.
- Oh, yeah.
We get that one all the time.
- Wait, what!
- I was like, yes, yes.
- Girls get that one all the time.
- Do it!
I wanna find the dude now,
- It's pretty bad.
- But I can't.
- I don't get that at all.
- They're trying to get your attention.
- That's because your fans are 14.
- Yeah, that's true.
They're 10 years old.
- That's because you
don't love her enough.
I'm just kidding.
- Yeah.
- They really see her,
and read her energy,
and know that that's exactly
what she wants to hear.
They're trying to get your attention.
- [Milo] Yeah.
- [Alexis] Yeah, that's true.
- I feel like a lot of these DMs
they know that maybe you're bored,
and you are gonna go through the requests,
you know what I mean?
And they need to stand out some way,
so they say, I wanna
do something like that.
- For sure.
They'll make group chats, like dudes.
- Oh my god.
I've been in a lot of group chats.
- Big dick energy, like group chats,
and it'll just be five guys
trying to get my attention,
- Oh geez.
- And the most inappropriate.
- It'd be way more clever if
it were little dick energy.
- That's not how you do it boys.
That's eye catching.
- A bunch of dude's little
dicks braggin' about it.
- That's eye catching.
- So if you're funny.
- What's your aim there?
- If everyone's like,
"Collectively we're 10 inches,
"there's 14 of us in this."
- All of us could not
please you together, but ultimately,
if you culled us all together.
I mean, there's so many, I'm on group.
People are group DMing me about you,
and they all have Milo.
They all have versions of
your name in their name
in their handles.
- Oh yes.
- Milo's pants, Milo's eye.
- Everything.
- Milo's shirts.
- If you make it up.
- Milo's left toe.
- Yeah, Milo's left toe
is definitely one of them.
- And I made the mistake
of engaging with them.
- There's definitely Milo's lobes.
I know for a fact.
- Lobes?
- But that's because you have that
weird thing where you like.
- Whitney has always been
touching my ear lobes
since we met, and that was like the thing.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- On Dancing with the Stars.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I always put posts
- Lucky.
- About it on my, exactly.
Posts about it on my story all the time,
and there was a bunch of
ear lobe accounts that
they literally, if I post a
picture with a water bottle,
it'll be like, Milo's
water bottle underscore.
- Oh, you know what they would do
to get that water bottle, man?
- [Milo] They would pay a lot of money.
- I used to be one of these girls,
and when you're obsessed with a guy,
and you're coming of age,
and you're having all
these feelings about boys
that you don't even understand,
and it's like lust.
It is, it's this intense energy.
- It's bad.
It's addiction.
- You feel like, "I will have him."
If we meet, we will date,
and I understand feeling
- It's going to happen.
- The fan, the standing
obsession of this guy
that you feel like you know,
and you're obsessed with
every little thing about him.
- Do you remember your first crush?
Like your first, first real one?
- Like star, celebrity crush?
- No, like a crush that was attainable?
That never happened.
- Yeah, but he wasn't
attainable.
- Yeah, like he was,
but he wasn't.
- Like he was in
my science class, but wasn't.
I mean, who was your first crush?
Do you remember?
- Oh my god, so I was homeschooled,
and in my homeschooling group.
- So your dad?
Just kidding.
You're like, it's just proximity.
Okay, so you were homeschooled.
No way.
- I was homeschooled
my entire life.
Never been in a classroom.
- What!
- Yeah, weird, right?
- Milo, bring her to school today.
Just to show her a classroom.
- [Milo] I know!
My school is a riot.
It would go crazy.
- No, I'm good.
But I do wanna come to your graduation.
- Oh, you're totally invited.
- I'm definitely gonna come.
- You're invited too,
by the way.
- Really?
- We should all cheer him on.
- I'm just gonna stand
outside by the way and watch.
I'm not invited.
(laughs)
Just wave from the outside.
Hey guys, is it fun?
Sir, we're arresting you.
I'm with that 17 year old boy.
(laughs)
(rock music)